le portillon de Charles de Gaulle donc
ça a dû normalement retirer de service
en 2038
et c'est ce qui pilote le calendrier du
porte-avion nouvelle génération première
sortie à la mer en 2036 et première et
donc finalement mise en service en 2038
au remplaçant le portement Charles de
Gaulle donc le
l'avis d'un bâtiment propulsant
nucléaire le portrait en Charles de
Gaulle par exemple et rythmé par ce
qu'on appelle des arrêts techniques
majeures le prochain arrêt technique
majeur du porte-avion aura lieu en 2027
il débutera en avril 27 et dura à peu
près entre 18 et 24 mois le c'est lors
de cet arrêt technique majeur parce que
là pour le coup la qualité le
vieillissement des aciers de cuve d'un
réacteur comme le la K15 qui est équipé
en Charles de Gaulle on ne peut pas
simuler avec la connaissance que l'on a
aujourd'hui du vieillissement de ces
matériaux on ne peut pas simuler son
vieillissement
et donc le juge de paix ça sera le
résultat de les examens qui vont être
réalisés à l'arrêt technique majeure qui
va s'étaler entre 27 et 29 et là on
pourra dire est-ce qu'on peut prolonger
la durée de vie du porte-avion ou pas la
question qui se posera à l'heure si on
veut prolonger alors c'est que la durée
de vie aujourd'hui d'un cœur qui pique
et équipe le porte-avion les cœurs de
chaufferie qui équipent le porte-avion
en général sont les cœurs les plus
sollicités puisque le de par l'emploi
opérationnel du porte-avion donc si on
veut prolonger le porte-avion au-delà de
sa durée de vie si prévisionnel si la
cuve le permet ça impliquera qu'on
change les deux cœurs parce qu'il y a un
cœur par chauffer nucléaire et donc là
ça impliquera des d'autres
considérations qu'on regarde comment on
peut fabriquer un deux coeur
supplémentaire dans le planning de
fabrication de docker on a un outil de
dissuasion en particulier sera
propulsion nucléaire qui est calé au
juste besoin c'est à dire qu'il nous
faut en gros un cœur par an fabriqué un
cœur par an donc il faut que j'en
rajoute de ils sont fabriqués à
Cadarache donc sous commandement de la
dame s'il faut qu'on rajoute deux cœurs
à un moment donné il va falloir pousser
autre chose voilà mais sinon rien n'est
impossible sur le sujet par contre le
juge de paix c'est pas avant 2027 donc
le résultat des expertises on va dire
fin 2027